is the new m2 macbook pro a lot better
than the m1 macbook pro well it actually
might be worse in a couple areas now in
this test we're going to compare
everything not only we're going to look
at the performance of the cpu and the
graphics we're going to see if the
speakers have been improved we're even
going to do a battery life test and
remove the bottom covers to see if apple
updated the design or gave it a better
fan to deal with the higher power usage
now on the exterior these things are
identical unfortunately the new one
still has just two ports on that side no
mag safe and the colors that they're
offering is the same thing and people
are even getting the same boxes but with
little stickers over the old stuff as
well the keyboards and track pads are
the same they both have the same touch
bar so this is the last macbook with the
touch bar now as far as the battery both
are unplugged right now but they have a
hundred percent charge and i went into
the battery information here you guys
could see that this one's brand new
cycle two but our m1 version it also has
a hundred percent battery capacity and
only 28 cycles proving how little we use
this over the air now both of these are
base models that have 8 gigs of ram and
256 gigs of ssd let's go ahead and
compare the speeds are you serious
apple how could you do this to us the m2
is slower than the m1 now we let this
run
multiple times the m1 speed is amazing
it got way faster than before but apple
put in slower ssds it's consistently
this performance i think the fastest we
saw on right was 1600 then drops down
1463 compared to
2215 on the right and on the read a
thousand 446 compared to 2
9
100 that is what
was that half the speed or less than
half that's exactly half the speed
and then we have a difference of about
800 or so on the right serious dude this
is actually not even fast enough to get
the full performance out of our sabrin's
external ssds the four terabyte we have
well i guess they're saving money not
only reusing the chassis the boxes but
putting in suckier ssds you know what
that also means
that a gig for the swap
that's gonna limit you more so because
the speed of the ssd is half a read and
you're reading from the ssd all right
well what else did they mess up here i
really hope that the speakers aren't any
quieter because that has happened before
[Applause]
now i don't know what to say is it
thankfully it didn't get worse or
unfortunately it didn't get any better
uh well they're practically the same and
as far as the webcams this is a 720p
webcam and the microphones from the m1
macbook pro and this is the same 720p
webcam and the microphones from the m2
macbook pro they have been using these
ever since
2016. so you guys let me know could you
tell the difference and now let's do
what nobody else has shown let's shut
these down and pull out our ifixit kit
to see if apple changed anything on the
inside could it have a better fan all
right and now let's open up the old one
i haven't seen the inside in about a
year and a half all right that explains
it the first thing that pops out are the
ssd chips right in the center on the m1
macbook pro we have two of them on the
m2 macbook pro we just have one and that
is why it's so slow the way it works is
when you have double the chips they kind
of work together almost like in a raid
with the ssd controller and they're way
faster than one as we saw with the
blackmagic disk speed test meaning apple
is saving money they are cheaping out
and in 2020 a year and a half later we
went way backwards in performance and
that is just to save the money now i
wonder with the m2 macbook air is it
also gonna be like this or will it even
be you know faster than the pro version
and right now if you spend as low as 850
bucks on an m1 macbook air you get
faster performance that's crazy we'll
leave a link down in the description now
everything else pretty much looks the
same our heatsink over here it looks
slightly different the corners aren't as
rounded not as refined as the old
version uh but the size is identical and
the fans they also look identical same
thing with the exhaust over here now the
m2 chip uses more power we saw that in
yesterday's video we tested it it gets
hot apple really should have put in a
second fan into this machine just like
they did with the previous four
thunderbolt port a 13 inch macbook pro
that would have really helped man apple
is cold-hearted or maybe it's just
getting really cold in here with our ac
vadim toss me that sweater this is our
m2 chip sweater
if you guys want to pick one up check
out the merch shelf down below and use
the code m2 chip no spaces if you want
to get 20
off and we'll also have a black and
white one as well if you want to go a
little bit more stealth super soft and
comfortable now let's go ahead and grab
these covers put them back on and get to
benchmarking now let's jump into
performance we're going to start out
with a quick geekbench test first off we
see that the m2 shows up to 3.49
gigahertz but in yesterday's test we
couldn't get it to go over 3.3 whereas
the m1 sits at 3.2 consistently let's
run it now one thing i noticed that we
had a difference in idle temperature
about 29.30 here compared to 3637 on the
m2 which is interesting and now just
playing this back where are you at 45
degrees rendering this start compared to
we just hit 31 on the m1 model so this
thing definitely heats up quicker all
right bam we have some scores and that's
actually the highest score we have seen
for the m2 chip very impressive now we
have a great scores for them and one but
the m2 is about 12 faster single core
and about 17 faster multi-core now this
single core score is the best out of any
laptop ever and we're on battery power
so now let's go ahead and switch over to
speedometer 2.0 here this is going to
test the snappiness of the system it
loads up stuff in your web browser when
you're you know surfing the web using uh
google docs all that kind of stuff all
right that is record breaking right
there
408 i dare you go around your computer
whatever you guys have that is crazy now
338 is extremely high as well apple's
been updating so far we have the latest
software so this has gone a lot faster
since it came out but 408 it's almost
double some of the best processors from
amd and intel now graphics is where the
m2 should be a lot better let's go ahead
and run our metal test because it has
two extra cores we're going from eight
cores to 10 gpu cores now this might be
the only reason to get an m2 macbook pro
look at that we have 30
842
compared to 21.5 that is uh over 43
percent faster bigger more of an
improvement than what apple even showed
off on stage at least for compute tasks
very very good and now let's push the
graphics to the extreme with 3d marks
wildlife the graphics chips are maxed
out right now there it is we have 41
frames per second compared to 30 frames
per second that's a difference of 36.6
once again slightly better than what
apple showed on stage so as far as a gpu
it's looking pretty good and now let's
really push these cpus to their limits
with cinebench now i also have
our power metrics open so we can see
exactly what's going on we can see our
fan speeds and we are going to do the 10
minute throttling test so we've been
running for about a minute now and we're
at 85 degrees celsius on the m1 and 93
degrees celsius 94 now on the m2 chip
now it is running at 200 megahertz
higher in the efficiency cores this is
one thing we didn't notice before those
are running close to about 400 megahertz
higher so of course we have four
performance cores for efficiency cores
so those kick up more so now as far as
our wattage we are running at an average
of about 16.7 about 20 watts and on the
m1 15. so that's a 5 watt difference
pretty significant and check this out
our fans on the m1 are already running
at
2300 they're kicking up they kicked up
earlier probably about maybe 10 20
seconds earlier than the m2 even though
the system is running cooler this is
already in 99 it was just at 100
compared to
i don't know what is this at here for
the top
the highest core is at 91. so the fan
curves are definitely different apple
did intentionally make this thing run
hotter and the fans kick in slower and
later than the m1 all right guys we are
halfway done and our m1 is running out
4200 rpm 4300 compared to hovering about
3600 with a 98 degrees celsius compared
to 89 it's a pretty significant
difference we now hit 101 and in our
previous video it actually hit up to 104
degrees and right now we have cold ac
just pumping into the room so it's
giving these a little bit of an
advantage all right we are done in we
have a difference of almost exactly a
thousand points now keep in mind these
monitoring tools do use a little bit of
power but this shows us a 13
improvement uh not the 18 that we've
seen on stage
but also it shows us that the m2 chip
uses 33 percent more power to get 13
more performance it's kind of like back
in the day when i would overclock
computers and you give a lot more power
for a small gain in performance now as
far as battery life let's do our first
check over here we have 78 on m2 and 74
on the m1 i'm not sure how that works
and why we're seeing the difference
because the brightness is the same
screens are the same this is using more
power but we're also just getting into
our tests that really pushed the system
now for you coders out there are you
going to be seeing that 13 to 18
difference in performance let's go ahead
and take a look with our xcode benchmark
all right we are done with a benchmark
the m1 macbook pro took two minutes and
18 seconds and the m2 took
two minutes and three seconds so that is
a gain of around 13
and now we are doing our logic test we
have both running right here this is a
new logic benchmark you guys can go look
it up and
unfortunately our m1 is actually running
faster or better it's handling more
tracks we're running at 81 and here we
got close to finishing with 76 but it
shut off now i don't know if it's a
background process maybe the ssd or i
don't know what's going on uh but this
definitely shows us that the m2 is not a
13 or you know 18 improvement so if
you're doing music production unless you
need that 24 gigabytes of ram fresher
plug-ins and you want to have this
specific macbook i don't think it's
worth it and now we have adobe lightroom
opened up for all the photo editors
we're also going to check out a
different program
but as far as the editing experience i
wouldn't expect to see much of a
difference with brushes or smoothness
it's mostly cpu based now we also do use
ram but also the ssds to load up images
so with the slower ssd
we possibly could see a difference now
we're going to go ahead and render these
50 raw images they're high resolution
and they have a bunch of effects bam we
are exporting and one difference with
the m2 chip is that you can get up to 24
gigs of ram as i mentioned but the ram
is actually faster as well so we'll see
how that plays into the results wow the
m2 was just at 105 degrees celsius the
highest we've seen so far
now the fans are starting to kick up and
um cool it off but it's also interesting
that the m1
is beating it out take a look at that oh
actually the m2 kicked in there at the
very end and beat it all right our test
is done
our m1 macbook pro took two minutes and
18 seconds actually faster than we had
before thanks to software updates and
the m2 was at exactly two minutes just
like i estimated in my previous video
now with that said that gives us a
difference of 15
which sounds like you know a decent
respectable amount but personally i was
expecting more because lightroom is very
ram dependent and cpu dependent and the
ram in the new m2 is 50
faster it uses super fast ram uh but
maybe because of the ssd or i don't know
why else the gain isn't that huge now we
can go ahead and shut down lightroom and
i'm going to test out affinity photo
because it is very well optimized and as
a benchmark now affinity uses way more
gpu compared to lightroom it actually
uses mostly gpu and that's a good thing
for the m2 because we have a difference
of 42
11 850 compared to 8
386 for the gpu score that is very
impressive now on the cpu side we're
only seeing a difference of about 13 7
55 compared to 667 so the cp performance
trend is continuing on and now i opened
up photoshop here i have some raw images
opened up that i'm going to use the
super resolution tool which uses a ai
so it's going to use the neural engine
and the m2 apple said that the
neural engine got 40
faster so let's take a look so we're
over halfway done and it looks like they
are pretty much neck and neck wow the m1
is actually slightly beating out the m2
right now all right wow that was very
weird our m1 took a minute and 58
seconds but the m2 took two minutes and
15 seconds now at first they were neck
and neck and then the m2 started getting
ahead and at the end all suddenly m1 won
i don't know if it just writes all the
files at the end and these are some
pretty massive high resolution files
that were made four times larger so
maybe it's just because of the faster
ssd's writing at the end but that is
pretty crazy and now it's time for all
of you 3d guys out there we have blender
opened up the latest version we are
running using the gpu compute through
cycles and let's go ahead and test out a
render on this tough party tug scene and
finally we're done that took a while we
have seven minutes and two seconds
compared to five minutes and 19 seconds
a difference of 32
now while that is decent it's not as
high as some we saw with you know for up
to 42 other tests i don't think anybody
that's serious about doing high quality
scenes like this is gonna want to get
the m2 especially if you have the m1 you
really do want to go for an m1 pro or
max because sitting here waiting like
this it's just taking way too long and
now finally on to video editing i have
final cut pro opened up in front of me
and we have a 4k project here with some
effects and some luts here and as far as
playback none of these are going to
struggle this is pretty easy but i want
to see if we have a difference in how
much cpu and gpu is needed to play this
back it's interesting the m2 is using
less cpu but more gpu whereas the m1 is
using less gpu but more cpu all right
let's go ahead and export this i want to
know does the m2 export faster apple
even talk about 8k which means it has to
have a higher frames per second to
export so will it be faster for video
editing let's find out alright guys look
at this they are exporting at the same
exact
time
this is 4k h.265 this is the faster
method to do it and the only difference
that we're seeing is that the m2 is only
using about 77 of its gpu compared to
about 93 from the m1 so even though we
have the extra graphics power unless
you're loading up enough effects and
transitions and tough things you might
not see any difference whatsoever and
this already has
film grain which takes quite a bit of
power and two luts on this compressed
footage so for most people that are
doing youtube youtube videos some more
simple stuff this is actually even the
m1 is gonna be more than enough for you
and as far as export times well it looks
like they're gonna be identical all
right guys i was wrong the m2 is faster
by two seconds two minutes 23 seconds
compared to two minutes and 25
seconds so for a lot of people that's
not gonna make a big difference but what
really stood out during the event was
the fact that it supports prores
encoding and decoding now just like the
ammon pro and max chips so let's go
ahead and open up a prores project here
this is a bunch of prores raw footage it
has a color corrections applied it has a
lut applied as well so this is fairly
easy for the max but if we take a look
at the cpu usage on the m1 we're at 42
percent
whereas on the m1 pro we're only at 14
that's because the prores
decoders they are actually doing most of
the heavy lifting because of that it
should be able to export this five
minute project quite a bit quicker so
let's go ahead and see all right guys
this is
utterly crazy
our m1
is 49 done right now 50 compared to 42
on the m2 chip
i don't know what is going wrong
i don't know if the pro res engines
aren't working properly yet i don't know
if we're waiting on software updates
like we did when the
max youtube came out it took a month to
get final cut to be updated
but yeah our
one and a half year old m1 is beating
out the m2 chip so far all right guys
our m1 finished and the m2
failed i don't know why i don't know if
there's software updates we need to wait
for stuff but this is just crazy i know
that we are going to do some more
testing on our next video we'll use
davinci resolve so we can get some more
data we'll also use some other codecs
but overall i'm quite a bit disappointed
we actually ran some other final
contests off screen and the results were
the same so it does seem to be a lot
more like the m 1.5 instead of the m2
even more than we thought now as far as
battery life i want to mention that uh
we did have some technical difficulties
as we were shooting this our m1 is at 23
percent our m2 is at 36 percent now we
had to reinstall different applications
had crashes so we spent more time on the
m1
but here's dave lee's uh excellent test
he had he had it early from apple and
this time instead of just doing light he
also has a heavy load so it does show
that under heavy load the m2 is actually
worse than that one but under a light
load it is a little bit better because
it has those efficiency cores that are
stronger it can rely on those more often
so thanks dave lee um and overall i just
have to say i'm a little bit more
disappointed than i even was during the
announcement just because the ssds are
half the speed for the read that is
insane for a product that came out a
year and a half later in 2022
and then some of the other things that
we were expecting the gains just aren't
that good i think if apple would have
put in maybe a magsafe connector a
better webcam maybe dual fans like we
used to have i mentioned at the
beginning in the 13-inch high-ren model
then it would run really quiet really
cool
uh and we'd have a noticeable kind of
worthwhile upgrade but at this point
either get a refurbished one save a ton
of money maybe a used m1 m1 macbook air
or if you need performance go for that
14 inch we're gonna do a full comparison
coming up showing you guys everything so
if you guys want to see that go ahead
and click that circle above and you'll
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there and give us your
thoughts down below this has been max
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you